a troubled horticulturalist a poetic
AIDS victim a wise and ruthless gang
Lord a trusting but deceived husband and
a glib and shady father these are the
five roles that were filled by five
exceptional actors here are the nominees
for performance by an actor in a
supporting role Chris Cooper and
adaptation Edie Harris in the hours
Paul Newman and Road to Perdition
see Riley in Chicago
Christopher Walken and catch me if you
have
and the Oscar goes to Chris Cooper and
adaptation
this is the first Academy Award and
for Chris Cooper
take this in for one second e from the
Academy to the womb that bore me thank
you and to all the nominees it's a
pleasure to be thought in your same
company to all the people in adaptation
who helped to make this the most
enjoyable job I ever had
thank you Charlie Kaufman Spike Jonze
Nicolas Cage the fabulous beautiful
wonderful Meryl Streep working with this
woman was like making great jazz and you
had a lot to do with this so thank you
to my wife Mary Ann you took on all the
burden thank you and in light of all the
troubles in this world I wish us all
peace thank you
you